hello this is world stories and I'm
sumitomo scanda thanks for joining us on
this week's edition we visit a gallery
that's making art accessible to the
blind we find out how Costa Rica's
banana growers are going green and how
Russia's Olympic preparations are taking
a toll on the environment but first
although its load of late India's
economy is still expanding by more than
five percent a year that growth means
the country is consuming vast amounts of
energy but most emerging markets are so
focused on growth that the switch from
fossil fuels to renewable energy has
taken a backseat still in northern India
a regional energy provider has decided
to invest in green technology a biomass
power facility is giving plant waste a
second lease on life both gebhardt shows
us how the state of Rajasthan is taking
clean energy production into its own
hands it takes more than one try to
unload this truck it's packed full with
chaff from surrounding farms
but the truck isn't dropping its load at
the dump it's dropping it at a power
plant where farm waste becomes valuable
biomass it's harvest time in the
southeastern part of india's rajasthan
state farmers are cutting mustard plants
one of the few crops that grow on such
dry lands formal honcho Audrey and his
family mustard plants mean financial
security YUM we funky lon eguren kahului
we're now harvesting mustard that we
sowed some four months ago Vijay gravy
horia pocket aro quiero escuchar today
we sell the kernels and bring what's
left to the power plant I you will go
visit the other the mustard needs to dry
for a week before it can be threshed
harvest waste mostly husks and stalks
are loaded onto trucks not too long ago
farmers used to burn the waste in their
fields today they sell it to Allen
Chopra the manager of an Indian power
company
six years ago he helped build a biomass
plant the seeds of the mustard plant are
processed into cooking oil but the rest
is used here
chopra will need a lot of farm waste to
cover anticipated demand over the coming
months we are buying a dress so that we
can generate power the quality of power
should be good there should be good
quantity of power available and it
should generate employment here in this
area this could mean more work for Mahan
Chaudhary like most farmers in the area
the 44 year-old delivers the waste to
the plant himself others use an
aggregator which saves time and gas all
told there are around 5000 farmers
within a 50 kilometer radius Chaudhary
receives his compensation as soon as the
delivery is Wade cathy feser I now we're
in forty percent more a year selling the
chaff to the power plant enemy without
rally villa using biomass instead of
coal means cleaner energy but the work
itself is dirty masks do little to
protect the lungs from dust the
collection group transports some 250
tons of biomass to the plant every day
now there's a slight crisis a conveyor
belt has gotten stuck but with good
salaries plant manager Chopra has
attracted talented engineers from around
India they keep the plant running
smoothly
burning farm waste releases the same
amount of carbon dioxide that the
mustard plants took in while growing
since the power plant no longer burns
coal it won't release an estimated
thirty six thousand tons of co2 annually
in comparison to poll the biomass
generates less carbon dioxide the
content of
guesses which are which are not
environment friendly are even if emitted
to the atmosphere are of a very very low
level turbines make electricity possible
using water pressure they create eight
megawatts of electricity then after
power 40,000 households like the
Chaudhary's home with the extra income
they were able to plant a second field
and expand their house vital improvement
for them and similar farming families
they also invest in their spirituality
and in their god Shiva the Hindu god of
destruction and rebirth by selling farm
waste their modest situation improved
enough for them to build a temple for
Shiva
others want to join them this mountain
of farm waste doesn't belong to the
plant but rather to a middleman what was
once worthless now has a market value
increasingly people are moving away from
coal and employing farm waste as fuel if
I don't buy that or the other company
it's good for the farmers more
competition means better prices you look
competent someone makes me an offer in
rupees someone else might come along and
offer double its give other give how
long as a farmer I sell to the buyer
offering the best price the other I was
purchasing the material at about 600
rupees ton and now i am paying 2,100
2,200 rupees per ton so the prices have
increased by more than three folds and
that is because of the competition even
though competitors might offer higher
prices farmers will still supply the
plant plant owners want to generate
power using biomass and the farmers want
to offer them a reliable supply
this will be a long-term revenue source
for them and this has increased their
quality of life so they are everybody's
happy that this plant has come everyone
benefits from the biomass plant it
supplies clean energy to the community
and improves the lives of the mustard
growers of Rajasthan now what is art
there are as many different answers to
that question as there are people on
this planet but when we talk about art
we think of seeing it with our own two
eyes something most of us take for
granted but what if you're blind how can
you appreciate a painting while an art
gallery in Bulgaria has come up with a
new project that makes famous paintings
accessible to those who can't see Nova
TV Sophie estoy teva explains for the
first time in his life
twenty-seven-year-old ivalo is able to
experience a painting by one of the old
masters following the instructions of
his audio guide his hand moves over a 3d
relief this painting represents a young
woman in a traditional Bulgarian costume
in the background are ripe pears ivalo
is instructed by an audio guide to feel
her hair and the classical features of
her face
he says that the recording also
describes colors because blind people
associate a very individual feeling with
each color guntur anelli tetonas nada
beijing theory I can imagine the outline
of the woman's face this way got the
cigarettes double virginities even more
do you think she's beautiful my story I
mean listen um well I don't know for me
beauty is an emotion it's a sensation
that makes me feel happy blueberry at
the moment he viola and other visitors
with impaired site can only access six
paintings this way a charity event is
intended to yield enough funds to
finance more south again we will darken
the entire gallery so seeing people can
experience how blind people see these
paintings the money raised will be used
to buy more 3d reliefs and audio guides
it's like a labyrinth and the audio
guide navigates me through it I have to
follow the instructions to figure out
where I am it's very exciting to explore
what the painting looks like a highly
enriching experience a promising
initiative for the visually impaired
rush of luxury Black Sea resort of Sochi
is getting ready for the 2014 winter
olympics thanks to its proximity to the
caucasus mountains the city is hoping to
provide one of the most spectacular
games ever sochi itself has one of the
mildest climates in russia some four
million people come here every year to
enjoy the sunshine on sochi's beaches
and the spectacular views of the nearby
mountains now the region is also a huge
building site in its bid to impress the
world with the Olympics but this
facelift is already taking its toll on
nature Alexander phenomen reports
sochi is situated on Russia's Black Sea
coast it's close to the Caucasus
Mountains home to one of the oldest
national parks in the country bloody Mia
kamiya came to love the area as a child
he and his parents used to go hiking
through the forests along the Black Sea
coast and today he's an environmental
activist who campaigns to protect the
region's unique subtropical nature the
solution is kid order it means a lot to
me here y'all she's a while every tree
every bush everybody you'd fly their
fate matters to you I grew up here and
I'm a nature lover I'm a local patriot
what this machine but now this sensitive
ecosystem is threatened gas pipes
streets tunnels and sports complexes are
under construction ahead of the 2014
winter olympics
these days Vladimir kamiya is confronted
by heavy machinery every time he goes
out walking he doesn't have much faith
in the government's promises to adhere
to green standards in its preparations
for the games yes I mean he was also
sure when you pick segolia special
there's no way they're trying to keep
the environmental damage to a minimum
trees have been cleared the rock face is
now barren wealthy the soil has been
churned up in order to make way for a
road for heavy vehicles yes yeah poor
little TV dodge ski jumps in the
mountains speed skating rinks near the
beach from the outset conservationists
have voiced concerns about the
environmental costs of the upcoming
games but sochi's organising committee
went ahead with plans regardless work is
almost finished in the Bay of emirati
neskaya what used to be a swamp area has
been reclaimed and developed into an
Olympic Park with six stadiums being
built by the state corporation olymp
straw gleb but let's of head of its
environmental Department maintains that
environmental concerns are a top
priority only that big cities
predicament everything is checked very
carefully first in the planning phase
and then we check out those plans are
being implemented and then we monitor
the environmental standards again before
any new project is put to use it's hope
that the Sochi Olympics will set new
green standards in sustainable
construction unprecedented in Russia
according to it but let's off they
include environmentally friendly
building materials rainwater tanks and
optimized insulation then what a third
nipple would look at that here at the
ice skating rink for example a special
glass is being used one of our green
standards is using energy-saving
materials
the school's Possible's no definitive
teacher bloody Mia kamiya has heard of
these green standards but he's not
pinning his hopes on them what he's seen
of the Olympic Park so far hasn't been
confidence inspiring the beach at Imura
teen Skaya Bay has been narrowed to make
way for a concrete beach promenade
restorable even minor storms wreak havoc
here the concrete walkway won't help
much when we get gale force winds the
rest of the beach will just get washed
away and the water levels will reach the
stadium's announced additional son
you're not in peace go
the countryside is proving vulnerable in
spring this housing estate a few streets
away was hit by a landslide many
residents were forced to leave their
homes they say the landslide was caused
by building rubble illegally deposited
on the slope above the estate let me at
my house sank two metres into a deep
hole in the ground how can I continue to
live there whether the shed doesn't
belong to me it belongs to my neighbor
but these landslides just keep on
happening and those responsible are
getting away with it locals living in
the shadow of the new Olympic Park feel
they'd been sidelined bloody Mia kamiya
is aware of the various environmental
threats posed by the Olympic project
some are serious some less so but they
all add up he has evidence of activities
at the river Sinta that no one could
dismiss as minor Vladimir Komarov and
other activists shot this footage in
summer they believe that chemicals used
during construction work are being
dumped into the river
they're having water samples tested to
confirm their fears but they can't
expect any help from the authorities
it's a viz upshift honesty those
responsible aren't interested in working
with us sometimes we feel we have no
choice but to access the building sites
illegally when we do the government in
the olympus Roy corporation condemn us
as extremists nothing the winter
olympics 2014 is modern russia's chance
to showcase itself to the world anyone
like vladimir kamiya who asks questions
or criticizes the current preparations
is seen as disloyal but that's not
enough to deter him from his mission
ensuring that the natural beauty of the
Caucasus remains intact one day he wants
to go walking in the hills with his
grandsons
now to a problem that's affecting
wildlife around the world illegal
poaching animal parts are trafficked
around the world just like drugs and
arms and that tray generates hundreds of
millions of dollars now the World
Wildlife Fund says that market is
booming and elephants and rhinos in
particular are vanishing fast in fact in
South Africa alone more than 630 rhinos
were killed by poachers last year andrew
martin from un TV takes us there for a
closer look at what authorities are
doing to combat wildlife crime rhinos
are facing their worst crisis in decades
over the last few years the number of
animals being poached has exploded
Kruger National Park in South Africa has
paid a heavy price for having the
largest rhino population in the world
ken nags is head of the South African
environmental crime investigation and
air services I believe it's it's a big
threat a huge problem for us at the
moment the worst case scenario is that
we lose every single runner on the
African continent rhinos have been near
extinction before there were about
100,000 black rhinos in the 1960s but
they were hunted and poached until just
two thousand four hundred remained
commercial trade in rhino horn was
banned by site ease the Convention on
International trade in endangered
species of wild fauna and flora in 1977
secretary-general of sight ease John
Scanlon if not for site ease the Rhino
would be extinct in the wild today it is
because of sight ease that the species
has recovered to the point where we now
have in the order of 25,000 Rhino on the
planet but as black market demand for
their horns continues to surge so does
the killing over the last few years
poaching in South Africa has skyrocketed
this species will be driven to
extinction in the wild if these trends
continue wildlife crime is estimated to
be worth billions of dollars a year
attracted by spiralling profits site
ease believes organized crime syndicates
sub moving in we have the poaching
groups well-armed from pistols due to
sophisticated military weapons AK
forty-sevens adequate ammunition we've
had poachers armed with hand grenades
rhino horn has been used in traditional
medicine in China and Vietnam for
centuries but the demand for
non-traditional uses is intensifying in
the emerging economies in Asia during
long time no talk I decided to buy this
piece because I'm getting old and I need
some medicine anaral right to heal while
um this hanoi resident paid two thousand
dollars for his piece of horn after 20
minutes of rubbing the horn against a
specifically designed bow with a drawing
of a rhino on the side he poured the
mixture into a glass and drank the milky
liquid n wen xia TV power i heard from
friends that this piece of rhino horn
can cure many diseases like stroke or
fever to argentine well time being
I heard the rumor that it can also cure
cancer come on Nana little too in the
markets of Hanoi it doesn't take long to
find rhino horn for sale but its
authenticity is questionable the site is
management Authority in Vietnam believes
a significant percentage of rhino horn
for sale in the market is fake the price
is 144 million didn't I mean stones for
100 grams there's 7,000 u.s. dollars the
only way we're going to tackle this
problem is by stopping the poaching
stopping the smuggling and stopping the
consuming the government of South Africa
is fighting back soldiers from the South
African National Defence Force have
deployed in kruger park and sightings is
supporting a new DNA database which is
aiming to profile the DNA of all of
Africa's rhinos the new technique will
allow any rhino horn seized by police at
border crossings to be identified
linking all perpetrators along the crime
chain and helping bring about a
prosecution this is going to be a tough
long fight but if we all work together
range States consumer states at national
level and international level we will
win this fight it is hoped that this new
international cooperation will be a
turning point in the protection of this
incredible species otherwise Africa's
reiners could slide over the brink into
extinction and finally to Costa Rica a
small Central American country with a
big reputation when it comes to
protecting the environment Costa Rica
has become a pioneer and sustainable
development from tourism to energy and
agriculture the country produces all
sorts of crops from coffee and sugar to
fruits in our next story canal 15 shows
us how researchers there are working to
expand banana production and keep the
plants pest free in a green way
banana farming has been traditionally
associated with agricultural methods
that rely on the use of pesticides now a
team of researchers in Costa Rica has
developed alternative techniques for
pest control nfo que nosotros consistent
escort our work focuses on four areas
reducing the use of pesticides restoring
the necessary quality of our soil or
throw SSD investigating how climate
change influences banana production and
the development of agronomic procedures
based on environmental sustainability
but my phone'll esselstyn you really are
this is the only way our research can
make a difference to science to the
environment and to society bag door
ultimately our objective is to provide
the consumer with a clean product and
promote the country as one of the
leading exporters of bananas worldwide
you killed place i go for a seal couple
that's the difference we want to provide
the consumer with high-quality bananas
but we also focus on the social aspect
the fact that the bananas are produced
in an environmentally friendly way de
como se producing que se produce que
bien que se pudo scan ammonia con
attitude alessa Jorge Sandoval is
director of research his project
specializes in the development of
biological monitoring of eco-friendly
procedures for farming bananas his
research team carries out lab
experiments on how to cultivate
microorganisms for pest control another
focus is the banana germ plasm bank
which preserves the genetic material of
143 different species hey Soph way
through zero materially representative
this is where we store the gene material
for a vast range of banana plants from
all over the world conca finale up our
objective is to find out which species
are resistant against certain diseases
or parasites that or are able to
tolerate them and we store genetic
reserves which might prove
useful in the future for preserving the
diversity of species medical / dental /
to the national banana corporations
research center in Costa Rica has drawn
high acclaim for its focus on
environmental issues it's considered a
state-of-the-art institution in Latin
America well that's all for this edition
of world stories will leave you with
this week's pics of the world see you
next time
No
just leave me as I this great book
you